Welcome to Module 07. Until now every model we trained was discriminative — given an input, predict a label. Generative modeling flips the question: given the data, learn to sample from the same distribution. GANs do this through a game. Two networks — a generator and a discriminator — train against each other, and neither one has access to an explicit likelihood. The magic is that the equilibrium of the game is exactly the data distribution.
The generator G takes a noise vector z sampled from a simple prior — typically a standard normal or uniform — and maps it to a synthetic sample. The discriminator D takes a sample, real or fake, and outputs the probability it came from the data. D wants to classify correctly; G wants to fool D. Neither sees a likelihood, neither sees a reconstruction loss — the only supervision is the discriminator's verdict flowing back through the generator by gradient.
The original minimax objective from Goodfellow's 2014 paper is simple to write and awkward to optimize. We want to maximize over D and minimize over G the expectation of log D of real plus log one minus D of G of z. In theory the global optimum has D equal to one half everywhere and G matching the data distribution. In practice the generator gradient saturates early — when D easily rejects G's samples, the log one minus D term has tiny gradient — so we use the non-saturating variant instead: G maximizes log D of G of z.
Training is a two-step loop. Sample a batch of real images and a batch of noise vectors, generate fakes, update D by one gradient step on the binary cross-entropy loss, then update G by one step pushing D's fake-prediction toward one. The ratio of D-steps to G-steps is a hyperparameter — usually one-to-one, sometimes five-to-one for Wasserstein variants. If you ever see the D loss collapse to near-zero, D has won the game and G will stop learning — that's the signature failure mode.
Mode collapse is the other signature failure. The generator discovers one or a handful of outputs that fool the discriminator and stops exploring. You'll see it in the samples — the same face over and over, or CIFAR-10 generating only frogs. The usual diagnostics are per-class coverage statistics on a labeled dataset, nearest-neighbor distance in feature space, or direct FID evaluation. Fixes range from architectural — adding minibatch discrimination — to objective-based, which is where Wasserstein GANs earn their keep.
DCGAN — Radford, Metz, Chintala, 2015 — was the first recipe that produced consistently believable images. The rules are specific: replace all pooling with strided and fractionally-strided convolutions, use batch normalization in both G and D except the G output and D input layers, remove fully-connected hidden layers, use ReLU in G with tanh at the output, and LeakyReLU in D. The Adam optimizer with learning rate 0.0002 and beta_1 at 0.5 instead of the usual 0.9 completes the recipe. Follow it — deviations usually hurt.
Conditional GANs extend both networks with a label. The generator takes the noise plus a one-hot class vector, the discriminator takes the image plus the same label, and training proceeds identically. Now G can sample class-conditional — generate only sevens, or only dogs — and the label signal stabilizes training by giving G a structured task. Auxiliary-classifier GANs go further: the discriminator predicts the class too, and the generator is penalized when its samples are unclassifiable.
Wasserstein GAN reframed the objective around Earth Mover's distance instead of Jensen-Shannon divergence. The critical insight: JS divergence is flat or undefined when the two distributions don't overlap, so gradients vanish. Wasserstein distance is smooth in that regime. The WGAN loss replaces log probabilities with raw scores — D becomes a critic, not a classifier — and requires the critic to be 1-Lipschitz. The original paper enforced this by weight clipping, which was fragile.
WGAN-GP — Gulrajani et al., 2017 — replaced weight clipping with a gradient penalty. You sample points on straight lines between real and fake examples, compute the critic's gradient with respect to those interpolated inputs, and add a penalty that pushes the gradient norm toward one. The penalty coefficient lambda is usually 10. This one change makes training dramatically more stable, removes most mode-collapse episodes, and has become the default for anyone training a GAN from scratch today.
StyleGAN — Karras et al., 2019 — reorganized the generator around the idea of style. Instead of feeding the noise directly into a stack of transposed convs, a mapping network turns z into an intermediate latent w. That w is injected at every resolution via adaptive instance normalization, controlling per-layer statistics of the feature maps. Coarse layers control pose and large-scale structure, mid layers control identity, fine layers control textures. The disentanglement is strong enough that you can do style mixing across two latents and get coherent results.
StyleGAN2 and StyleGAN3 refined the recipe — weight demodulation replaced AdaIN to remove characteristic artifacts, path-length regularization smoothed the latent space, and StyleGAN3 fixed aliasing by making every layer translation-equivariant. These are the models behind the "this person does not exist" demos. On the academic side they're also the reference point for disentanglement and latent-space editing research.
Evaluation is harder than it looks. Inception Score — IS — runs a pretrained Inception-V3 on samples and measures the KL divergence between the per-sample class distribution and the marginal. High IS means samples are confident and diverse. The problem: IS is blind to whether samples match the data distribution at all — a GAN that only generates a few perfect ImageNet classes scores well. Report IS but never alone.
Fréchet Inception Distance — FID — is the default today. Run Inception-V3 on real and generated samples, take the pool-3 features, fit a Gaussian to each set, then compute the Fréchet distance between the two Gaussians. Lower is better, zero is identical. FID catches mode collapse because a collapsed generator's feature mean and covariance drift from the reals. Standard practice is 50,000 samples; smaller counts have high variance and comparisons across papers with different sample sizes are meaningless.
Common training pitfalls worth calling out. First, normalization mismatch: if your real images are in [-1, 1] but your generator outputs sigmoid in [0, 1], D learns to classify by range alone and G never catches up — always verify the ranges match. Second, BatchNorm in the discriminator mixes statistics across real and fake batches and leaks information — use LayerNorm or InstanceNorm in WGAN-GP critics. Third, forgetting to detach the generator's output when updating D will back-propagate into G on the wrong step.
The labs walk this stack in order. Start with a one-dimensional toy GAN — a generator learning to fit a mixture of Gaussians — where you can plot the full density and see mode collapse happen in real time. Move to DCGAN on MNIST and CIFAR-10. Add conditioning. Swap the objective for WGAN-GP and observe the stability difference. Finally, load a pretrained StyleGAN2 checkpoint and explore latent-space interpolation and style mixing without retraining.
Two meta-pitfalls for the labs. First, don't trust samples at epoch one hundred — always compute FID on a held-out pool of 10,000 samples before declaring the run "done". Visual cherry-picking lies. Second, GANs are stochastic; a seed that looks great at one batch size may collapse at another. Fix the seed, fix the batch size, and log the FID every N epochs so you can spot a regression the moment it starts.
That's generative adversarial networks. A minimax game, a non-saturating generator loss, Wasserstein distance with a gradient penalty for stability, DCGAN's architectural rules as a baseline, style-based generators for disentangled control, and FID as the scoring metric that actually correlates with sample quality. Module 08 moves to a very different generative paradigm — language modeling with Transformers. Onward.